estos días de invierno oscurece
muchísimo más temprano hoy ha nevado en
levit Y a esta hora que ya oscurece las
luces de estas calles una de las
principales de la ciudad ya tendrían que
estar prendidas pero no lo están por las
restricciones energéticas a las que está
sometida esta ciudad y el resto de
Ucrania que ha visto como las fuerzas
rusas han atacado sistemáticamente la
infraestructura energética a partir del
10 de octubre
detrás está el Palacio de la ópera y
toda esta Plaza uno de los lugares más
emblemáticos de la ciudad estuvo
totalmente a oscuras el pasado 15 de
noviembre después de uno de los mayores
ataques rusos contra la infraestructura
energética no solamente esta parte
occidental del país sino de toda Ucrania
aquí nos cuentan que si viene aquí la
energía se ha ido restableciendo
entonces no es así en otros lugares de
la ciudad especialmente las viviendas
donde sienten constantemente los cortes
eléctricos la gente piensa en el próximo
ataque y temen que la situación sea peor
Pero aún así intentan dejar el miedo La
mayoría ha vuelto al trabajo y volver a
vivir la vida lo que les preocupa más es
la situación en el frente de batalla
[Música]
en esta parte del occidente del país
saben que son Realmente
Afortunados comparados con otras
regiones que son constantemente atacadas
sin embargo aquí temen que esos ataques
sistemáticos contra la infraestructura
energética sean cada vez peor Y esto
tiene consecuencias no solamente en los
apagones dentro de sus casas sino en el
acceso al agua y a la calefacción hoy
así uno de los primeros días en que ha
nevado y ya empiezan a sentir las
consecuencias de estos ataques el
presidente polo de mí selenski ha
hablado de 10 millones de personas en
Ucrania sin acceso a la electricidad